yellow welcome to this video um yeah I
announced two days ago that I would
start on Monday today reporting on the
olympiad but um yeah I made a mistake it
is starting today but it's just the
opening ceremony so the first round with
actual chest being played as tomorrow so
on I have no video with real game
content to show but I was just coming
across a fun site that I found I was
told about them about around the chess
olympiad and this is called fantasy
chess team calm um it's quite fun what
you can do here what you can do it you
can pick your fantasy team of the chess
olympiad for both the open section and
and to the the women's section and it is
basically working in a way that you you
enter your name your mail address and
you get there to name your fantasy team
and then you start selecting players who
you would think make a big score at the
ilume yet and it all adds up every day
and at the end possibly you you chose
the right players to become the winner
of this fantasy chess team contest
there's also an option to to pay I don't
know five pounds on yeah UK pounds um
two together money price I well I didn't
do that but i did a a free entry you can
also just play for fun you have to
select these five boards there's also
reserve board and get the winner of the
individual sections and the overall best
performers so i think it's a fun fun
thing to do this is often done for other
team sports like football or soccer in
the US as it's called on I guess any
other team sports where you can select
them players for the teams yeah so maybe
check out the side and enter your team
as well I also place an entry so you can
also compare your performance to mine
the site also i think this is a good
idea to do is got some hints and tips
and resources I mean I didn't invest
like hours to put my team together but
especially the hints and tips are useful
to read because it's an it's paramount
and to understand that only the total
points are important not rating
performance so um it's it's then it's
also not permitted to just select
players of one team so let's say you
sing well thank you you think the
Russians might win this so you pick the
whole Russian team this is not possible
you need to pick five different
countries yeah all right so um maybe you
have fun with those kind of games as
well I always enjoy this kind of stuff
guessing results and so on so maybe you
like this as well and want to enter you
check out the side and I'll be back
tomorrow with the coverage from the
first round which most probably would
see lots of very uneven pairings but
this is always fun because um you
sometimes have yeah some giants losing
22 yeah smaller countries yeah let's
talk tomorrow about the first round and
see you then